l'année 2020 les a éprouvé mais rien
n'arrêtera le couple lavergne à la tête
du restaurant familial et gastronomique
la maison des bois
jenny et laurent ont rouvert leurs
établissements il y a seulement un mois
en plus de la crise sanitaire un
incendie a ravagé une partie du
restaurant en juin dernier
ça s'est passé tout simplement un court
circuit dans les combles suite aux
experts des pompiers des assurances on
sortait juste du premier confinement
donc ça a été très compliqué on va dire
juillet août le temps de trouver les
entreprises on en a profité pour
rebondir se dit bon on va aller de
l'avant maintenant voilà le kobe ne nous
a pas eu la première fois bella sont
dits non plus créé en 1926 est tenu par
la même famille de génération en
génération
l' incendie a été un choc mais après de
nombreux travaux pour refaire
l'intégralité de la salle comme le toit
en chaume ou encore remplacer les
historiques poutres apparentes
le couple la vergne s'est lancé dans la
vente à emporter
on a commencé uniquement la vente à
emporter à la fin des travaux suite à
l'incendié du restaurant donc ça ne fait
que maintenant on va faire un mois
vraiment qu'on fait de la vente à
emporter
au début on était un peu timide parce
qu'on voulait surtout contacter les gens
qui l'avaient soutenu après un incendie
puis maintenant ça commence à prendre de
l'ampleur
et on essaye de garder notre qualité
donc on préfère bloquer le nombre donc
faire un gros volume et de l'ampleur il
y en avait le week-end dernier pour la
saint valentin une grosse période pour
la maison des bois
les habitués étaient au rendez vous sur
trois jours plus de 200 commandes ont
été vendus